-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning journalis
who co-hosts "CBS This Morning,"
weekdays, beginning at 7:00 a.m.
Her Sirius XM show,
"Gayle King In The House,"
airs Thursdays
on Stars, channel 109.
Please welcome back to the show,
our good friend
and editor at large
of "Oprah Daily," Gayle King
Hello, Gayle.
How are you?
-Hello, Seth!
Hello.
Seth, you should've seen me.
I'm staying up late for you,
because I get up
at 3:30 in the morning.
But just now, I was leaning in
going, "Is that Fred?
Is that Fred?"
And darn, it's Fred!
-It's Fred. Fred is --
-Wow!
-You know, he's still managing
to make this work,
even though
he's in London right now.
Pretty impressive,
our friendship.
You know, some people say
it's the most famous celebrity
friendship in America.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I'm all for it.
I'm so sorry
I can't be there in person
-He wants to start "F Magazine,"
and I keep saying,
"I don't think so."
-Yeah. No, no.
No, no.
I keep saying, can you believe
Seth, we are still --
I'm still in my living room.
At least
you're back in the studio.
-I know.
-But I'm still here.
-Well, you've done an amazin
job hosting a morning show
The last time we talked
was in August.
Obviously, we have a new
president since then.
And certainly news from th
White House is a little quieter.
But you are still,
much like we have to do here
talking about COVID
every single day.
How are you managing?
-Well, at least --
This is the thing.
At least I get to go
into the studio now.
And I find -- Listen, I told you
this about me before.
I'm very much a people person.
You know, I tell you, I miss
the people I don't even like
But at least
I get to go into the studio.
I'm grateful that I get to
at least leave the four walls.
I've been vaccinated
and everything,
but I'm still
just super cautious.
-I also feel very grateful
to be back in studio
and to have received a shot.
How do you feel about
your vaccination?
Are you enthusiastic?
Are you over the moon?
-How do I even say this?
When I got the second shot
I don't even know why
I felt so emotional.
But I'm finding a lot of peopl
are doing this,
because I felt so grateful
I felt so grateful.
The minute that they had upped
it where my category was okay,
I tried not to trample
little children when they said
"You're now eligible."
But I felt so grateful
that I could --
that I got through COVID,
that --
And now I know that
if I do get it --
you know, knock on wood,
I hope I don't --
but if I do,
at least it won't be --
at least I feel
I have some coverage.
But now we got the friggin
variants to worry about, so...
You know, I see there's ligh
at the end of the tunnel, Seth
but we're still in the tunnel.
And I don't want people
to forget that.
But there is light
at the tunnel,
but we're not
out of the woods yet.
-We certainly aren't.
And I think it'll be nice
for everybody
to get out of the woods.
One thing that I would expec
that you might do,
you've talked about being single
and how dating, obviously,
incredibly hard
during the pandemic.
-Yeah.
-Are you looking forward -
Are there any deal breakers,
I guess, I would ask,
when someone goes on a dat
with Gayle King?
-Now, I don't want
to sound elitist.
I don't know, Seth.
You're putting me on the spot.
But I prefer
if you have your teeth.
-Oh, okay.
-I like that.
I like teeth.
-Yeah.
I don't think
that's as elitist --
You set that up to be
a little bit more...
-No, no, but, you know?
-You know, "I prefer
country club membership"
would be elitist.
-Well, some people could think
it's snobby, but I do like -
Smoking, I have to say,
is a deal breaker for me.
I just -- I think it gets
in your clothes.
I think it affects your health
But I want you to know
I'm stepping out of my box
It used to be tattoos.
I'm now opening myself up
to tattoos.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, I know.
I'm very proud of me.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I just want somebody
that's kind, smart, funny,
that's aware of current events
that would be good.
-That's interesting to me,
because obviously
you're so engaged
with current events,
I thought there would mayb
be a chance that you'd want,
you know, your personal life
you wouldn't care
if somebody wasn't
up to speed on things.
-Oh, no.
I definitely care about that
-Yeah.
-Because I think it's importan
to be informed
about what's going on.
I really do.
You may not know every littl
niggly detail like I do.
I feel like I know every littl
niggly detail about the news
'cause I watch it.
I come in the front door,
the first thing I do
is turn on the TV.
I mean, I like knowing
what's going on.
So, I'm not saying you have to
be as deep in the weeds as I am,
but at least have some knowledge
that, you know,
we have a new president
or who was at the inauguration
Like you just said a minute ago,
we have a new president.
I mean, just something as simple
as the service that they had
for the officer
who was killed the other day
you know, one of the childre
of the officer
dropped the stuffed animal
and how President Biden
got out of his seat,
picked up the animal,
and gave it to the little girl
was just so touching
and sweet to me, you know?
I crave that kind of humanity.
And I think that
it's a good thing to see.
-You had one of the most
wonderful celebrations
any human could have this year
which is your daughter
got married.
-Yes.
-And yet, she had to suffe
through a very small wedding
-[ Laughs ]
It was small, Seth.
There was only six people.
So, favorite daughter Kirby,
her fiancé, now husband,
my favorite son Will,
who actually did the ceremony.
He was supposed to marry friends
of his in March,
so he had
all of his credentials.
And that wedding was canceled.
And Oprah, who's her godmother
and Stedman.
It was just the six of us.
But they got to get marrie
in Oprah's rose garden.
So that wasn't so bad.
-[ Laughs ]
I also feel like,
with the exchange rate,
if Oprah's at your wedding, it
means it was a thousand people
[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
Well, you would be wrong,
Mr. Meyers.
It was just the six of us.
Just the six of us.
But you know what, Seth?
Do you know what's
so great about that is tha
it wasn't the plan that,
you know --
'Cause I had dreamed of the,
you know, walking down the aisle
and a lot of people and flowers.
I don't know.
That might
not have been her dream,
but that was certainly mine.
So all of that --
And I would zip her up
in her dress.
I didn't even get to do that
because Oprah's so --
She's taking COVID
very, very seriously
that if you go, you have
to quarantine for 14 days.
I literally
flew in and flew out.
I was actually in the air
more than I was
long at the wedding service.
So I didn't get to zip her u
in her dress
or any of that cool stuff,
but Oprah did it.
So I felt -- So I knew tha
she was in good hands.
But just to have something
so small, so private,
so intimate,
it really worked out okay.
And --
And you'll like this.
Oprah was having a shoot
on her property the day before
so there was a professiona
photographer, Joe Pugliese
who did the pictures, who stayed
an extra day to do the pictures.
So we got --
'cause I had gone --
Ready with my iPhone.
I was there with the iPhone.
But Joe stayed, and we got
beautiful, beautiful pictures.
So all in all,
it was really wonderful.
-Well, congratulations...
-Thanks.
-...to her and you, as well.
-Seth, I'm a mother-in-law
I'm a mother-in-law.
I'm trying to be a good one.
-Do you think so far
you have been a good one?
-[ Chuckles ]
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Seth, let's go with that
-Yeah, that's good.
Yeah, and me, I'm very lucky
I have no complaints
about my mother-in-law at all.
I want to finish by asking
"O Magazine" is being revamped
-Yes.
-It's now OprahDaily.com.
-Yeah.
-Is this an exciting transitio
for you and Oprah?
-We're very proud of it,
because, you know,
the print edition
stopped at the end of 2020
the monthly.
And Oprah said,
"We're not ending.
It's not ending,
it's an evolution."
She's very pro digital.
So we have "Oprah Daily."
You know, we call it, you know
living your best life and living
it well on a daily basis.
Oprah's there.
The beauty of Daily and digita
is that you can instantly
keep up with everything
that's going on.
And we're gonna do
four print edition --
four print editions.
-Oh, that's great.
-And so we have "Oprah Daily."
You can an be Oprah Insider,
Seth, for a small nominal fee,
where you get special stuf
just from Oprah herself.
Go ahead.
-Oh, I thought you were asking
me to be, like,
"Write an article,"
and be that kind of
Oprah Insider.
You were just selling me.
You were just trying
to sell me on it.
-Yes, I am. Yes, I am.
[ Laughter ]
Listen, if you want to write
something, we would love that.
-Well, I'll be too busy signin
up to be an Oprah Insider.
[ Laughter ]
-We would love that.
-Hey, it is always such
a delight to see you, Gayle.
Thanks for making time for us.
-Thank you, Seth.
I can't wait
to see you in person.
How are you holding up, though
being there without an audienc
and without people?
Are you getting --
Do you like it?
Do you --
-I'm so happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you?
-I'm so deeply happy about it.
Yeah.
-I don't believe you.
-I love --
I mean, don't get me wrong
I love, love, love
that there's an audience
at home watching.
-Yeah.
-But being here by myself...
-Is okay?
-It's the dream.
-Okay. Well, I can't wait to
see you in person, Mr. Meyers.
-I haven't had a joke bomb
in nine months.
-I can't wait.
[ Laughter ]
"CBS This Morning"
airs weekdays at 7:00 a.m.